read my lips we're gonna watch a bad lip
reading
I've got Tara here with me hey you doing
Terra Terra has a blog called talk and
Tara Wow
dot-com thanks so much make sure to go
check it out what do you talk about
their life lost love and a little bit of
fun
excellent relatable topics sure I'm
happy for you I also got a YouTube
channel you just checked out oh you guys
check that out Tara did you watch the
Super Bowl
I didn't mean either so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna watch bad lip reading
NFL 20/20 the best way to watch it let's
do this some guy named Pui Cui's boring
man thousand T screw fish - opposite
janitor snout lint birds do nothing else
[Music]
marionettes okay you want to buy my
electric guitar you could buy the things
that has made me famous ah [ __ ] rain
Paulo Tosh president three powerful it's
no this is just a bunch of super - it's
not Super Bowl maybe bother Ark pagina
later oh no baby I could Murph on that
down baby up put some clothes on that
Merc
some clothing that murky towel and
generate your own life get in the stance
of which stands this one here is this
right you should be nice to me
yeah here I should be nice to up your
whole habit to tell you I saw you sniff
your shoe your face is a face I've been
avoiding for seven years have to look
back at it I'll break down for show guys
thunder hands Hilton dunk rug look Brock
1,000 babies exclusive is sunset
Mitchell Han ah okay who take Logan
Valencia Hey what am I looking at and
lightning
cam return right load wait no hold you
Thanks trying to catch a ball guess you
think the scoring just sort of happens
hmm y'all are disgusting everyone y'all
cannot talk to me anymore
hey you have bad sense no because I mean
nobody has bad sense no no sure somebody
somebody does I look like I'm five now
let me zoom you so good shouldn't be
like picking up a snail and music of
rock and Danny you know I've got over 41
traffic cones it's my pleasure native
people have Anita Pico talk about tofu
baby look a third man that wants la
Fontaine generic tongue taste jersey
tote a goblin breast wrap a pencil not
so juice
hey you ever hear the cracking I heard
you did that Joffe is the horses size I
don't have my book and this is boring
ah you ever hear of world wide
watermelon or the world wide watermelon
plot look porcupine
quit showing off while bertha stalking
is included don't ever take a baby I
swear I went to doctor school granny oh
because my foot was out well Nikes neck
bone I should sketch that neck bone okay
take it all out on the universe didn't
you ever hear cardio it's a kid hey
where's the kite seven corpses in the
dead
I like chunks in my coffee yeah my
temperature is six Fahrenheit I keep the
Gopher tomorrow and they're like really
don't find your gopher yeah I took it
back to the garden Oh sandwich ability
is not something that you would ever
want yeah Rorschach tock tock little
badger balls
Laporte diphthong Bon Appetit Junior
Horace sophistical hey Brighton Brady go
kiss your stepmother hey my bike is gone
man does anybody seen it cuz my bike is
gone it's spoken name is Michael my
friend of my ride has anybody else seen
Michael emotion is about my fingers are
filthy job to Venice it's America hey
let me check for love you
stop the Rhino attacks number one in
female situations I collect pictures of
horses acting when they make a bowl wow
that's cool
really you letting the bagel King they
let in the bagel King how is he even
here problem with your filthy pol Pamela
[Music]
mark bark
hoo-hah Lucy fun wise sassafras Simon
asterisk Carlton the seeker shipwreck
shipwreck
hey hey hey excuse me at one minute
Steve I bless your fingers Stephen stop
doing that fool ah bless your fingers
and obviously you must not leave - fine
- fine shoved in my locker it hurt yeah
the whole seven days no Devlin's a bad
guy yeah always know the Devlin is a bad
guy and they're always just sort of
sketchy all right dog is enormous
hey brewskis you like our house gasps I
would like a doodle of your aunt it's
important to hey dickweed I want to Club
his job mother soda
I saw a stump at the Franklin Mall I'm
tired
wait a sec where's Tanya honestly I
don't trust my heart Oh shouldn't fun
worlds Oh bollocks
so the coke Gilligan bouncy house snip
snip
get in my car we're taking hostage I
don't think that New York hey the cars
this way it's time for lesson boys the
sweet scent of almost dying all night I
thought I heard the chick from frozen
just there's roaches at my party do you
have any life this is such a random
video clown pepper plum party machine
Oracle of Eden not true Polly's prancing
puzzles your father you want to go back
to picking bananas waterfall here my
prayers Oh gorgeous triplets with a good
face oh my grandma said that her friends
are gonna find you a girlfriend no
freakin way dude a girlfriend look at
the speck of dust here I'm gonna touch
your back no need to panic gonna get a
smile dankey lava lamps equal tank sir
evelyn akhator ha crowd stay on g53
buster liveth i said since steel grip
xiv my favorite Oh small tragedy that's
basically in the lava I'm afraid so he's
not to blame ha
candy still just sitting here with not
candy quiet desperation of the macaws
in Suffern honor the days candy still
just sitting here without candy that is
easily the most football I've watched in
years my favorite ones where when they
were showing footage at the game and
then they were cutting to little
snippets of people being interviewed
like close-up yeah over there the random
stuff they were saying it boggles my
mind how they put this together
first off I'm watching this and I
thought it was just going to be the
Super Bowl it's clearly a bunch of other
football games all compiled into one so
the amount of assembly of footage the
amount of editing I imagine there's a
lot on the cutting room floor but how do
they go about scripting this or figuring
out what funny dialogue to put into
someone grab the clips they mute the
audio and then they have someone else go
what do you think they're saying and
then they just try to interpret it
because I've seen like improv games like
that words like puppets that kind of the
game that they're doing with themselves
when they're trying to script one of
these together because especially
something like this which is a whole
bunch of different games this takes a
lot of work and a lot of compiling it do
I say we test it now you're gonna say
something without the words coming out
then you'll say it again and I'm gonna
try to say the words okay so you melt it
you mouth it and then I'm gonna look at
it once the second time I'll say the
word you know we'll make this even more
interesting we're gonna play some music
just for you to put the headphones on
okay well put on just some instrumental
stuff all right
got a beat to it so I need a like really
not hear you say it out loud and then
mouth it and then I guess yeah I'll put
a text on straight of what I'm gonna say
okay so I'm
[Music]
okay okay now what do we say now you
have a mouth at once so I can see it now
I'm gonna try to do it okay okay wait no
all right I'm hoping in the other room
I'm not gonna like you you wouldn't I'm
not gonna do it again do it again
farting in the other room there it is I
farted in the other room right yeah okay
you gotta do a harder one okay there you
go
okay Jesus mother and holy a God help me
Oh Oh the Shawshank Redemption is the
best film of all how do you know that I
could read your lips
we're like good at lip reading okay do
one more and like I don't know I'm
really good at seeing what the next time
you're putting sometimes I might be
saying it a little bit this third one
you're gonna keep the headphones on okay
good idea
okay cuz I did okay yeah
[Music]
I'm something the mall waited again
I do lip-syncing at them all I saw
something something at the mall Marlee
Gibson Oh Miley Cyrus no my get oh my
god whatever take it up we're gonna do
Mel Gibson now I think I might be good
at that was I mean I was really a nut
see you know we didn't do bad liberating
what we did was the whisper challenge
really trying to guess it's fine we did
what we did
yeah we she was trying to be yeah yeah
because I can't have a lip-reading
expert because a lip reader would just
read whatever it is the thing they have
to just make it into what they think it
is that's what I'm saying so if you just
left bleep me say anything to the camera
I can't hear you and then I'm gonna lip
read it but with my own words okay go I
will look at you
[Music]
[Laughter]
you told me you were gonna buy us pizza
huh you told me you were gonna buy us
pizza huh
subscribe at lipreading plug in her
channel subscribe to rage of the day
Sara coming her way Andrew Hayes buddy
our longtime loyal patronage ex friend
of the real rejects and his last
shoutout I didn't mention that he is the
best man at an upcoming wedding so he's
trying to lose weight I thought to help
him get some action at the wedding I
wrote a little poem here that might
inspire the ladies who happen to stumble
upon this who might be at the wedding to
maybe consider him his name is andrew
laeddis lookout he will pursue you and
try to screw you and believe me you'll
want him to his last name is Hayes and
homeboy will put you in a love haze
you'll tell us yourself nope
scratch that you'll tell yourself it's
just a phase as your heart is sent into
a craze you're the best man at the
wedding
make sure your hotel has clean bedding
oh yeah I think I got us d monetized
with this ending I think that's the best
shout out you've ever gotten I think it
should be a ramp